the question is will the suitcase closed
we're on our way to Austria definitely
shutting way more in here than this I
think it's gonna actually close well if
that's the case I'm gonna put one more
item in there one more sweater because
why not oh I also had to leave half of
the things that I had packed to all the
stuff on the floor was previously inside
of my suitcase but I said no gotta draw
the line somewhere I'm only gonna be
there for a few days I don't know what
else I have either but honestly we're
not going for very long I realize it's
the same weekly returns yeah I packed a
lot for not a lot of time
[Music]
step one if one get to the airport
we made it okay it might be dramatic but
this has happened many times before I
usually carry a very heavy backpack that
I normally am smart enough to bring a
ruler bag because and you tie my
backpack is too heavy it with so much
pressure on my shoulders that I start
feeling light-headed and I want to pass
out my backpack so we're gonna be
redistributing everything but we made it
to the lounge we have how much time do
we have
11 hour flight flight a Munich and then
we fly to Graz and then that's as far as
I know what's happening as well done
that I have every single USB cable that
was made in the past 20 years so we're
definitely set
[Music]
there is a hot spot up there
that means Wi-Fi all blacks is happening
[Music]
learning German over here
right
[Music]
we were traveling last year we were in
the Munich Airport so many times
[Music]
I made a really super silly mistake I
thought I was getting regular water but
it boxberger water and I waited in line
probably like 30 minutes to get this and
I had two options I had classic and had
natural I was like what classic sounds
like it would be classic
don't know I'm thirsty so never make
this mistake again because boobs are
means
I'm definitely pronouncing that wrong
please with carbonate
[Music]
it's snowing we don't have dragons could
we check that
[Music]
Hey hi so I'm in Austria right now and
I'm waiting for my sister to come over
to my room
because we are gonna go out and explore
today one of the things that you guys
told me on Twitter is there's currently
a cold front coming through Europe right
now so we kind of chose the coldest time
possible to come to Austria but why I am
here is I'm doing the launch of the new
Jaguar ipace it's a new electric vehicle
that they're announcing or potentially
when you're watching this they've
already announced it but now I gotta get
suited up because it's super cold out
here we go
[Music]
so it's been great because you're here
with Jaguar they have a car for us so we
have some we're driving us around and
taking us some cool destinations
now we have picked out on a map but he's
not actually from Graz so he doesn't
really know the street that well so
we're kind of sort of trying to figure
this out together
I'm trying to find the clock tower
I don't think that's right where we want
to go we're going inside of a rock is
this where we go to die why did we
decide hey let's go inside the dark
dungeon I don't know the driver said to
get on there he didn't live here see the
clock tower was up we're going down into
the earth it's just good to look real
quick because we're here they're all
there's a soda machine
oh she's wow that really was quite
shocked I okay let's go back I don't I'm
I feel like this is some sort of
archeological dinosaur dig and I know
that were supposed to be going up so
this is not really restaurant toilets
clock tower it's right there
yeah we gotta we gotta go somewhere warm
this is chilly
coming up unto the Clocktower now
something that we've been searching for
for the past 35 minutes
you
[Music]
we go in it I almost fell
how do you say cold in German it's been
cold no so we saw a bunch of nice views
up here and now we have another place
that we want to go it's like this little
glass bridge and everyone said that we
have to go check it out it's on the way
to a museum and there's also a cafe
inside so from here that's how we're
gonna try to go that's it that's what
we're going to go from there and then
the other museums over there how we get
there I don't know I got walking
directions and it basically he said hey
be careful cuz these directions are in
beta and the walking directions took us
basically walking over top of buildings
where do you think this elevator goes
you need to get tickets or does it take
us well should we try it
no look English here do tickets but this
can take us somewhere oh this takes us
to a downhill look let's take it but
where does it take us oh no get in go
get your camera back this one okay no we
don't wanna go junior sneaks we really
want to go oh my god I just got
instantly terrified I don't know where
we're going I bet you they have no right
where we showed up woke up this is where
we started except I'm not sure if this
is
I don't think this is exactly where we
came out though that's a problem we
might be somewhere else in the pictures
actually yet I saw this as well so I
think room here we possibly could even
walk to that place this is actually one
of my favorite lenses for this camera
it's a 16 to 70 so you can get super
super long
[Music]
he lets you shop who dis back out into
the cold we have delicious lunch and now
we're gonna go check out the museum they
said this is called the friendly alien
I have to store over items within
bloggers all right see you guys later
I'm gonna put you in the water
[Music]
so I think it's important to look at
these things as formative experiment
[Music]